it's very hard to get recognition
as a business person or as an
entrepreneur and not just as a scientist
when i came up with this idea i i went
to different people and different vcs
and all of them thought that oh it's
very cute it's very
it's very insightful and i'm we're very
glad to know that this technology exists
but you are aiming to an unknown market
you are targeting an unknown technology
in that industry
and of course you are going to face
utilities or
governmental
entities which is very hard in the
entrepreneurship world
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet lauren
guy cto and co-founder of utilis
lauren is an entrepreneur by heart and
an avid fan of using the power of remote
sensing to achieve the impossible lauren
co-founded utilis in 2013 with a novel
approach to finding water leaks from
space with a master in geophysics and a
bachelor in hydrology and geomorphology
lauren wroten executed algorithms being
used in intellis he possesses seven
patents in remote sensing and sar
lauren guy welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
great thank you for having me i'm great
i'm doing great i'm always excited when
when i know that i'm about to approach a
conversation where i'm going to learn
something that that i that i definitely
did not know before you have such an
interesting background from a bachelor's
of science and geomorphology and remote
sensing you'll tell me what that is in a
second from ben gurion university and
then masters of science in atmospheric
physics and dynamics from the hebrew
university for the past eight years the
cto and co-founder of utilities so so
tell me a little bit a little bit again
about about geophysics just so that we
have a streamline a streamlined
conversation so geophysics basically
describes the relationship with between
physics and different uh
um interactions that happens in the
atmosphere of the world around us and
and space
um
together with the geosciences which is
uh geology geography and geomorphology
and everything that relates to geology
and the interaction between them that's
basically what geophysics is about
and and so if we look today at where we
are in terms of the world what are some
what are some of the pending questions
that geophysicists might be concerning
themselves with that are really
interesting
so we can so we can divide that to two
things we can start with uh other
planets or
space which is a big thing for
geoscientists and this is actually where
i came from so as i worked on my master
and other studies and we were actually
focusing on how we can find water
on mars and because we cannot work on
mars yet we use satellites
uh
to find water and then of course we
cannot see water on on the surface of
mars and if there is water or indication
of water it has to be under the ground
so as a geophysicist you try to find a
certain wavelength like microwave
that can actually penetrate the ground
and you can see water even hundreds of
meters below the surface
and so
i guess that's purely through different
mathematic different mathematical based
algorithms that you're trying to isolate
you know what what's happening without
actually visualizing it
correct so so as you as we know the
humans know how to take different
wavelengths and to contribute them into
our you know our day-to-day lives we all
know x-rays which enable us to see
uh
through the body we along infrared which
enable us to see heat or to see in the
dark
and what microwave is exactly like that
microwave has other capabilities and one
of them is of course
penetrating the soil but it's also other
very cool capabilities like locating
water very very well
it can uh
it can actually
move through clouds and different
weather so we all know google satellites
images where suddenly you want to see a
certain place and there's a cloud
blocking everything
and with microwave this phenomenon will
not happen because microwave can
penetrate the clouds and basically
clouds are transparent to it that's why
by the way a
microwave is big not only for
geophysicists but also for the defense
industry for apparent reasons
uh so definitely uh
all right okay and so obviously a lot of
the things that we're talking about you
know they're very heavily research based
and you know looking forward um you know
now into the more the you know the the
actual business sector and and the the
different
you know opportunities that there are in
the business world for asking such
questions when you when you go back
eight years as a scientist and a
physicist
what how do you go about thinking how
can you actually commercialize some of
this some of these understandings
so when i finish my studies i actually
look for a way to contribute what i
learned
into actual insight to something
actually can help the planet
and as a person go that grown in israel
we always been aware around water we've
always been aware of conserving water
so water was a is it wasn't still a big
issue in israel so that was my first
go-to market
but still we all know where there are
water on on earth so it's not really
relevant and then i dig even more and i
learned an amazing number that 30
percent of the water that we are
transporting to the end customers are
being lost into leakages which is quite
an amazing number think about water we
are taking from reservoirs even hundreds
of hundreds of miles away from the
client you transport them and just a few
feet before the client is just go into
the leak so think about about the amount
of water that's being lost
even more than that think about the
energy
an amazing number that i learned in
california for example and it's quite
similar in other
states and even developed other
countries
that 17
1 7
of the energy of the country is pushing
water now think out of those 17
30 on leakages
think about the huge amount of energy
and water that we just waste into the
ground so one two so once i found out
that this vertical as
actual issues with no real solutions
that's how i decided to focus on the
water leakages market and how we can use
satellites and microwaves and sensors in
order to solve that
so so let's dive deep into that because
that's fascinating how do you actually
solve use satellites and and those
microwaves to to figure out
where the leakages are
yeah so in 2013 i founded utilis and
utrecht is a data company we do not
operate satellites
we do not operate outwards and so on we
just rent airtime for different
satellites around the globe uh more
precisely microwave satellites there are
some and that's that orbiting earth as
we speak
and what we basically say to the
satellite please take an image of
san diego for example the next week
it give us the raw images in microwave
sense meaning it doesn't look exactly
like we all know in optical images it's
basically
a matrix of numbers of different returns
or signals we're getting from the soil
and we take this raw data and we analyze
it and we actually
looking for not only water but
more precisely treated water we can tell
the difference from space which i think
is quite fascinating if the water that
you have in your cup now is water or
it's rain or it's treated water we can
tell the difference
and once we got to that
capability we have the assumption that
if there is little water under the
ground it has to come from a leak
and from a pipe and that's how the
entire technology and solution and
market evolved around that
and so when you're when you're just
starting out you know as a scientist
what what steps now is on the
entrepreneurial side how do you actually
go about and and you know partner with
with those operating the satellites and
figure out who can you sell this
information to i mean obviously there's
a big gap between you know doing your
bachelors and masters in the subject
becoming a domain expert in this but
then actually going and p and and
piecing everything together
uh and piecing the information together
to actually sell it
so i can divide it into answers actually
so the first transfer answer is
exactly what you described it's very
hard to get recognition
as a business person or as an
entrepreneur and not just as a scientist
uh when i came up with this idea i i
went to different people and different
vcs and all of them thought that oh it's
very cute it's very
it's very insightful and
we're very glad to know that this
technology exists
but you are aiming to an unknown market
you are targeting an unknown technology
in that industry
and of course you are going to face
utilities or
governmental
entities which is very hard in the
entrepreneurship world so that was
the first barrier the second barrier
which was i was quite surprised was the
actually the clients i was in the
beginning i was quite sure that when i
will come to the clients with this
solution clients meaning utilities and
around the globe
they will just you know the water
providers the ones in the supply chain
yes
yeah i was pretty sure that they will
line up to buy the solution because it's
so cool and there are no other solutions
for that
and i learned that no one waited for me
even though you can bring a new
technology into a very old-fashioned
market it doesn't mean they will jump on
you
instantly it's actually the opposite
because they are used to doing things so
old-fashioned and just doing it manually
or actually even doing nothing
you can come with the best idea ever
it doesn't mean that they will
necessarily buy your solution so
actually the first obstacle was
actually teaching the the market that
this solution can benefit them does
actual roi and it's not just cool
and then slowly and surely
uh the clients were more um agreeing to
accept that technology
and with a lot of with a lot of effort
by the way by customer success managers
and uh you know holding them or holding
them by hand and showing them
the actual meaning of looking for
leakages yeah
now what was it that turned the table do
you think you know in this in this case
was it you know when they saw a leak
that they weren't aware of that they saw
how efficient it could be what was the
turning point
so i can tell you the turning point for
me and the turning point for the client
the turning point for me was our first
client in israel which was tel aviv
we gave them but by the way they were
very skeptical about that solution it's
um like some charlatan coming from space
and telling them where to dig with with
a weird x-ray vision but they agreed to
to be a part of a certain pilot and i
sent them to a certain location i still
remember the street it was on nordau
street in tel aviv we went to that
location
the contractor on on site was was also
very skeptical he told us there was no
leak here i'm sure of that but because
the utility agreed to take part of the
pilot it dug
and once he started digging there was a
huge leak surfacing the surface and that
was the first you know wow moment for me
that this technology actually works
that's for my side from the utility side
was actually our first client in the us
which is a very big utility on the west
coast
um
and we delivered them thousands of leaks
and they started to fix in those leaks
and saying 12 months after that they
actually reduced the
leakages percentage from 25 to even 20
or 15
with only one year which usually the
which usually they only decrease that
maybe by half a percent a year so like
20 times better that was a big wow
moment also for the market and of course
for me as well
and so i can only you know i think that
one thing that is important to to then
understand here is that these leaks are
actually happening under the ground you
cannot visualize them as you're roaming
the streets you know i i actually live
on
on nordau so and i'm i'm imagining
walking walking on the street and having
no idea that there's a leak underneath
me but but i but going back to that
story when you're digging when you're
there and you're digging and you're
seeing that there's a leak what is the
reaction because you mentioned that the
wow factor happened with the client in
the us but i can only i can't imagine
there not being a wow factor
back in tel aviv when they're digging
this hole
so there was a wow factor even for the
clients i cannot deny that but
again the market was very skeptical in
the beginning because we are a
statistical solution meaning not every
lick we send to the client is actually a
leak
and israelis love to focus on the bad
things sometimes not just the good
things
so
for example we gave tel aviv 10 lips in
the beginning and only
four of them were correct meaning six
were nothing
and that's created some skepticism but
that's part of teaching the market the
true value because let's take
the solution before you till this game
before we came they may be found one
leak a day by just walking the streets
and listening to pipes right vb acoustic
methods and just looking for the lick
and maybe maybe they found one leak a
day
now utilities came we give them 10
locations a day and you know what with
only 30 success rate they find three
leagues a day
this is still three times better than
what they do now today we're around 90
which is much much better but showing
them the roi not just focusing on a
single leak haven't we found it or not
that was the true game changer for the
clients as well it was very hard in the
beginning very hard in israel
by the way but eventually
the number just popped out and you
cannot deny the actual contribute
to the system
and so what's happening today so fast
forward a few years
you've been running for quite some time
you have a lot of people working with
you a lot of really amazing people what
what's happening today with utilities
around the world
yeah so again i started the loan in 2013
right now utilities are around is around
60 people in
in the us israel in the uk with three
offices
uh and although we started as a water
leak detection company and my son called
me a plumber from space
we don't see ourselves
we don't see ourselves as a water
company we see ourselves as an insight
as a service company meaning we are not
only focusing focusing on the water
vertical we're also focusing on other
verticals where microwave can contribute
to that
mainly for infrastructure and mainly for
earth sciences
not defense or other stuff
but
indeed we give insights to different
utilities or private companies or even
bi insights to the to end clients about
what's going on in the soil what's going
on with different infrastructure on the
soil
uh soil moisture and so on and so on
right now utilis is working in 55
countries
by the way the only way to achieve 55
countries in seven eight years is remote
sensing and again that's the true power
of satellites right i can sit at my home
with boxers in my backyard just telling
the study like to take an image and
that's it i get the data you analyze
that and give the results even to the
other side of the world and you know
what we worked with dubai even five
years ago where israel didn't have
relationship with dubai so that's the
full power of
of using remote sensing uh we have
around 400 clients around the world we
found 35 000 licks
wow which is a huge number we found
seven billion gallons of water per year
wow which also is the huge amount of
water
not to say the energy
so the impact
yes so we're very proud of the solution
i i love it these are exactly the sort
of companies that get me excited uh you
know the the the impact is you know is
huge and we can only you know we can
play a really a really quick simulation
of how this impact then goes and
translates into the daily life of every
person in this world and and the and the
butterfly effect of it over the years
and and i think it's just it's just
incredible it did and and i think
another very cool thing is that a lot of
people always wonder why we spend so
much money on space
why we have the race for mars while
we're spending money on satellites why
would we just waste money when we have
real issues on our globe and that's
exactly the the reason scientists using
you know space and and
and research around space not define
solutions to what we have here on earth
because space or other planets give us
insights that it's very hard to see on
our globe and
that's the way to do it so amazing it is
a smart investment that showed dividends
of course
i i love it lauren thank you so much for
sharing this time with me i really
appreciate it
i before we leave i have a few last
questions to get to know you a little
bit better and and i want you to go back
to your childhood you know before you
know like even with with geo with the
geophysics
is this really what fascinates you as a
kid before you reach
academia yeah so
my mom always loved to say that i went
to sleep since i was six with with an
atlas
so geography was always a big thing for
me and i slept with the soil maps and
theology maps and just maps of the world
and actually collected atlas from all
around the world with different
versions so yes geography and you know
the planet was always big for me since
very very early early age and i'm glad
i'm still operating in that market
and if you go today even looked at in
your life what what inspires you in your
day to day
so what inspires me and it might sounds
like a cliche but when i look on other
startups especially in the data industry
it's very hard to see how those startups
can really contribute the world and not
just the shareholders of that company
and that's not saying anything wrong
about those companies but for me it's
very hard to see the value of the end
clients you know it doesn't have to be
like the globe even even
companies that give data for specific
lines it's very hard to know what they
are actually selling and what's the roi
and that's what what's the value and
what it inspires me and what's actually
inspires
our old team and actually
and also the investors around my team is
that our solution is very clear
very intuitive and you can actually see
the dividends of what you do
uh
to everything energy water
carbon emission and
stuff like that so that's for me it's a
real inspiration
and if i were to ask somebody that works
with you either as a client or as a
partner as an employee
what how would they what words would
they use to describe lauren
so the first thing that everyone will
describe me as is optimistics
someone shows me an issue and i'm
instantly finding on a way to solve that
issue and
that's compared to other
let's say developers or other rnd guys
which the
favorite answer is no that's not
possible i always try to think for a way
to do that even
too much or even amazing optimistics
then my r d director always tell me why
we are why we are wasting time on that
thing
and eventually it shows dividends
because i think that if you really spend
your time on finding a solution to
something you can find it in a in
in a certain way in one one way or
another so optimism is certainly
something that always evolved me
and you say two more things right
you choose
any words that would describe you yes
also i think i'm a very calm person
uh everything is very laid back and that
also shows how utilities operates we are
not in a rush you know to get to the end
goal or to the exit
or to you know to really
end this journey we're very calm we're
very laid back
our official statement is to help the
resiliency of this planet and we are
doing this very slowly and very surely
without me you know a real speed to do
that as fast as possible so i think
that's a great way to describe me and to
describe beautylists as well
um
and that's it i think i can think about
the third thing right now wonderful well
lauren i really want to thank you both
for these 20 minutes but really for the
last eight years and the amazing work
that you're doing the impact that you're
having on the lives of many others the
impact that you will have and so i'll
take this opportunity to think at least
on my behalf and i and i just love this
combination of deep research with with
the commercialization and the and
positive impact and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very much
thank you for having me
you